bon vers les
régions
il nous entend
par jour
pardon sepang beethoven
bon bien habillé vous vous connaissez
toutes façons tous les deux nous a
battus et les amis on joue au tennis on
sent absolument et à partir de minuit je
dois dire que cet homme est un escroc
c'est un plan de carrière il a dit c'est
10 h accueil après ils avaient jeté ou
under et charles il s'est dit il ya un
créneau accord et fanny l'avenir du
monde
qu'est ce qu'ils font là les préférés de
clara morgane ah ben je vais dire être
qu'une
il voit très bien une place très bien
nous
[Applaudissements]
et c'est gilbert à 6,3 kg alors je dis
mais
ça veut dire que la fin ça me regarde
pas mais la braguette de tom est ouvert
et c'est apparemment
ce n'était rien lui échappera à bras et
bravo gilbert louis finances et j'ai
pris misère dans le pays que de l'autre
côté d'eux mais non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sans un petit d'altesse toi c'est quoi
pour gilbert huawei sa blindtest tactile
je vais te donner des objets il faut que
tu les reconnaissent je peux bouger
raquette
petit minet raquette de tennis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une semaine plus tard ding ding pour
appeler les gens que les gens voient
plus ton serviteur m
[Applaudissements]
je m'attends au pire avec lui l'accord
dakar c'est basile asie gilbert du
muscle c'est
aussi ces des jumelles qu'il est fort
[Musique]
tu as dix secondes mais je mêle
pas c'est un jeu de lego c'est un nom
formé le bienfait merano fait le
[Musique]
plus dur ah ouais plus dur
c'est quoi ça c'est un jeu c'est un
outil oui
à lecci
enfin s'est inscrite et tout le mondial
c'est un cd a cédé 2 qui se plaît à
temps je regarde c'est le mien ouais
[Applaudissements]
j'avoue qu'il reconnaisse on dit et le
dernier la la c'est quoi moi j'ai pas
c'est quoi je sais pas même nom sais pas
je te rassure alors c'est une sculpture
ouais moi j'adore quand je vais au musée
rodin chaleur touché un rodin ah ouais
ouais
reconnaissante et jeux de mots c'est
peut-être baiser le baiser de rodin
là je me verrais bien plus parce que m'a
bluffé gilbert gilbert g combien de
doigts au nom tu peux me faire ça tous
les voyants une fosse à quand j'étais
petit temps à 5 ouais
non voulues zappez pas tant la veille
mon petit doigt dans la 3
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
laisse tomber tant attendu qu'un
ya des vibrations je pense qu'on peut
pas comprendre en tout cas échéant
l'appareil consomme annoncé
report des voix
la cliente
[Applaudissements]
ce lien
faire et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de nos latitudes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu